since the creation of bitcoin the
world's richest crypto holder who got
the majority of their wealth from crypto
was always satoshi nakamoto
this isn't really that surprising given
that satoshi created bitcoin and owns a
total of 1 million bitcoins which was
equivalent to nearly 70 billion dollars
at the peak over the past year though
there have been rumors in the community
that satoshi may have been displaced by
champion zhao or cz
but there was never any confirmation
from sources like forbes or bloomberg in
fact as recently as november 2021 yahoo
reported cc's net worth to be just two
billion dollars which is a far cry from
satoshi's tens of billions but more
recently bloomberg added cc to their
billionaires list and he's come in
around the 90 to 100 billion mark and
that doesn't even include his personal
crypto holdings just five years ago
though cece's net worth likely didn't
even cross the 100 million dollar mark
so here's how cz made 100 billion
dollars in five years and became the
world's richest crypto billionaire
[Music]
taking a look back sisi was born on
september 10th 1977 in the jiangsu
province of china both of his parents
were teachers by trade but this didn't
last very long after cece's birth you
see cesi's father worked at a university
and was known for having pro-bourgeois
beliefs bourgeois simply refers to
middle and upper middle class people so
that would mean that caesar's father had
pro-middle-class beliefs but such
beliefs were found upon in china and
over time pressure mounted for caesar's
father to leave the university so
shortly after cece's birth the family
exiled to a rural area this is where cz
spent the majority of his early
childhood but when he was 12 years old
his family decided to move to vancouver
canada it's not clear what his parents
did for a living in canada but it
definitely wasn't that lucrative cz had
to pick up a number of minimum wage
service jobs throughout his teenage
years including working at a few gas
stations and a mcdonald's moving into
his college years cece attended mcgill
university in montreal quebec where he
majored in computer science considering
this training in cs i don't think you'd
be surprised to hear that cz found an
internship as a software developer out
of college but it wasn't at a tech
company it was actually at the tokyo
stock exchange cze worked for a
subcontractor of the tokyo stock
exchange who was responsible for
developing software for matching buy and
sell orders after his time in tokyo cece
secured a full-time job at bloomberg
great book in 2001. here cz worked as a
developer for futures trading software
which lasted for about four years until
he left in 2005. while cz was
technically a software developer his
entire career was based on the financial
sector many software engineers would
probably find this quite boring and
would rather work at an innovative tech
company but cz didn't mind in fact he
spotted great opportunity within the
trading world and this led him to found
his first company
[Music]
one of the biggest shortfalls of the
financial industry is that they're
usually one of the last industries to
adopt new technologies take bank
transfers for example most banks still
use ach transfers to move around money
despite the technology being created in
1972.
usually this is because with the
financial industry large amounts of
money are involved and the people are
reluctant to trust newer systems but
when a technological advantage is
undebatably better people do usually
come around and this is what cz was
betting on in 2005 cz founded fusion
systems in shanghai china the company
specialized in developing high frequency
trading systems for stock brokers that
could replace their old clunky systems
the company also provided it consulting
services as well fusion systems never
turned into a billion dollar company but
it looks like it was enough to provide
cz with a well-off life he ran the
company up until 2013 when he heard
about something called the bitcoin cd's
introduction to bitcoin and dates back
to a poker game with his friends in the
early 2010s one of his friends mentioned
a bitcoin and described what it was
trying to accomplish cz wasn't instantly
sold but he was intrigued and it didn't
take him long to go down the bitcoin
rabbit hole he started off by just
buying some bitcoin and then he sold his
house and put it all in bitcoin and yes
that escalated fast also let's not
forget that this was way back in the
2013 slash 2014 bitcoin bore run
selling your house and going all in on
bitcoin is not smart even today and
that's with significant institutional
support and a market cap of around one
trillion dollars back in 2013 bitcoin's
market cap was just one billion dollars
for most of the year and the
overwhelming sentiment was that bitcoin
was a scam that was going to zero so i
have no clue how cz was so confident on
top of gambling his entire net worth on
bitcoin cz decided to leave fusion
systems and to get a job within the
cryptocurrency space so cz was literally
all in on bitcoin
[Music]
cece's first job within the cryptoverse
was at blockchain.com blockchain.com was
the original provider of cryptocurrency
wallets and exchange services between
2012 and 2020 they accounted for 28 of
all bitcoin transactions over the past
few years blockchain.com has lost a lot
of its appeal as many consumers have
switched over to more convenient
brokerages like coinbase gemini and of
course binance but back in the day
blockchain.com was the go-to place for
bitcoin and cz joined as the third
member of the company's cryptocurrency
wallet team cz helped with the software
development for the wallet for one year
before he switched over to ok coin as
cto
at the time ok coin was a rather new
platform being founded in 2013. unlike
blockchain.com which was mainly designed
as a place to hold crypto okay coin was
more focused on enabling customers to
invest and trade with ease today ok coin
has grown into being one of the largest
crypto brokerages in the world with over
100 000 investors and traders so it
wouldn't have been a bad bet to stay
with ok coin but cz felt that he could
create a much better brokerage he
already had a decade worth of experience
developing high frequency stock trading
systems and now he had a pretty solid
understanding of the blockchain so in
2015 cj decided to combine his knowledge
and found bg tech the company was based
in shanghai and focused on providing
crypto exchange services to local
residents bg tech chalked along for two
years until suddenly in 2017 all of bg's
platforms and websites went dead there
was never any explanation as to why bg
was shut down and if it was intentional
we all know that china is not a big fan
of crypto so maybe the shutdown can be
explained by political pressure or maybe
it's easy shutdown bg on purpose in
order to launch a more refined and
stable exchange we may never find out
why bg was shut down but what we do know
is that this was just the beginning of
cc's crypto journey
[Music]
cz was determined to launch another
crypto brokerage but he had very little
cash left and he was by no means willing
to sell his bitcoin so he went to the
public markets for help in 2017 cz
launched new cryptocurrency called the
binance coin which was built on the
ethereum network the initial coin
offering raised a total of 15 million
dollars which he used to launch the
binance exchange in july of 2017. to
this day cc claims that he only holds
two cryptos which are of course bitcoin
and binance coin he says that the
majority of his personal crypto holdings
is binance coin and he has no plans of
changing this cesi believes that keeping
the majority of his personal wealth in
finance keeps him loyal and committed to
the company long term
anyway despite the young nature of
finance traders flooded in almost
immediately as binance was specifically
designed for high frequency trading
within just eight months finance became
the world's largest cryptocurrency
exchange in terms of trading volume and
the cz leverages popularity to launch a
blockchain network called the binance
smart chain as the name suggests this
was a new crypto blockchain but this
chain was more similar to ethereum's
blockchain than it was the bitcoins
blockchain given that was focused on
default applications this includes perks
such as smart contracts cross-chain
transfers and reduced block times aside
from launching a cryptocurrency cz also
launched a stable coin in 2018. the goal
with the stablecoin was to allow people
to enjoy the benefits of cryptocurrency
and blockchain technology without all
the volatility cz started off by
partnering with three other exchanges
and raising a total of 32 million
dollars which they used to launch busd
which is apparently back to one-to-one
with us dollars moving into 2019 finance
partnered with an israeli payment
processor called simplex which allowed
for cryptocurrency purchases to be made
with a debit and credit cards despite
all these great expansion efforts though
it wasn't all smooth selling for binance
[Music]
from the very beginning one of the
biggest challenges binance faced was
regulation in september of 2017 china
announced that they were going to ban
cryptocurrency trading within the
country so cz had to move all of binance
operations to japan this worked for a
couple of months but it didn't take long
for japan to start cracking down on
cryptocurrency trading as well so in
march of 2018 finance expanded their
operations to the island of malta and
they formed a memorandum of
understanding with the government of
bermuda this finally allowed them to
continue operations without the fear of
being shut down but they were still
missing out on the largest market in the
world because the us banned banyans in
2019. as a result finance had to launch
a u.s specific version called the
binance.us which complies with u.s
brokerage rules this wasn't the end of
the regulation nightmare either even
today finance is under investigation by
the us for tax evasion and money
laundering but these regulatory issues
would pale in comparison to what would
unfold in 2019. on a may 7th 2019 a
group of hackers used phishing and
viruses to steal 7 000 bitcoins or 40
million dollars worth of bitcoins from
binance fortunately this was only two
percent of binance's total holdings and
they were able to cover the losses out
of pocket but this has become a
permanent black mark on their reputation
aside from having to deal with hackers
finance has also had to deal with quite
a bit of angry customers you see it
crypto is still a pretty young
technology and exchanges aren't always
perfect outages still happen from time
to time and though bananas likely has a
clause that says that they're not
responsible for losses caused by outages
some traders are trying to pursue
charges and reclaim losses nonetheless
honestly i don't think this case will go
anywhere but it's just another hassle
that binance has to deal with as well
[Music]
despite all these challenges binance is
still the largest crypto brokerage in
the world in terms of volume since
they're a private company they don't
release the revenue and earnings numbers
but we do know that binance processes up
to 170 billion worth of crypto trades
every day to put that in perspective
coinbase has a daily trade volume of
just 2 billion per day now of course
coinbase is not a trading platform but
given that the majority of these
brokerages make their money on
transactional fees volume is extremely
important for profit even with just two
billion dollars in volume every day
coinbase is valued at 50 billion dollars
so i don't think you'd be surprised to
hear that finance is worth well above
100 billion dollars looking forward cz
aims to donate the vast majority of his
wealth as a 90 plus to charity so it
looks like the wealth has found its way
to good hands and that's how cz went
from 100 million dollars to 100 billion
dollars in five years would you guys
have gone all in on bitcoin in 2013
comment that down below
also drop a like if you hope that cz
follows through with this charitable
promise and of course check out our
international channels if you would like
to see these videos in other languages
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm hari and i'll see you guys on
the next one
[Music]